live families and community members are
taking a stand against full-time
distance learning today a group is
gathering
outside of ccsd headquarters tonight to
emphasize what they call the
importance of in-person instruction
sasha loftis joins us live near sahara
and decatur on this very important issue
brian good evening definitely already a
large presence here now ccsd police have
the actual parking lot
of ccsd headquarters blocked off so this
group is gathering here
along the sidewalk and this side street
now this protest is officially
expected to start at 5 30 but you can
see already a very
large group gathering here as those
community members speak out against
full-time
distance learning the main goal of
tonight's event to demonstrate that
in-person learning is essential
after ccsd started this school year
completely online monday
nevada state senator scott hammond is
expected to speak he is here now
along with special education advocate
jody thornley they are expected to touch
on what they call the negative impacts
of
at home learning now another sticking
point here is the number of kids that
still don't have internet access that's
around 70
000 or about 20 percent of the
district's
student population now back out here
live the ccsd board of trustees will
hold a regular board meeting tonight
they are expected to hopefully give an
update on the number of students that
they are trying to connect with either
internet
or chromebooks we will of course have
updates on this as this particular event
and as that board meeting develops
for now reporting live sasha loftis 8
news now